hallo liebe zuschauer wir haben heute
besuch von henrik aus dänemark hallo
henrik macht auch videos auf dänisch und
zwar bei unseren partnern von identisch
und ihr könnt jetzt zum beispiel mal
hier kriegen da gibt es ein video von
identisch dann seht ihr wie denis
gesprochen wird
und heute hatte henrik eine super idee
wir wollen mal gucken wie ähnlich sind
eigentlich deutsch und dänisch was
denkst du henrik ziemlich ähnlich ja
ungefähr 40 prozent aller dänische
wörter kommen aus niederdeutsch
also ja also sollte ziemlich ähnlich
sein eigentlich ich denke das dänisch
eine ja ich denke eine sprache ist die
wenn man sie liest ähnlich aussieht aber
wenn ich sie höre klingt ist für mich
völlig anders als deutschland für mich
ging das immer so als hättest du eine
kartoffel alonso ja dass das sagen viele
leute aber aber wir können das ja wir
können das ja mal probieren und soja das
ja henrik hat eine liste erstellt mit
wörtern aus deutschen aus dem deutschen
und ausländischen die sehr ähnlich sind
und die zeigen wir euch jetzt
werkstatt werks dax dax fliese fließen
schon mal sehr ähnlicher tag denkschule
skole weil das nicht ein bisschen anders
ja also man hat die auf deutsch gesagt
man aber auch auf den ich ist ssk und
wieso sagt man da steht jetzt dachte
aber er sagte ja also was sollte man
sonst also sonst wäre es ja so
normalerweise wenn wenn das g am ende
kommt dann spricht man jetzt nicht so
deutlich aus ist nicht so wichtig nicht
so deutlich da ist einfach gar nichts
hält fit lampe lampe die kartoffel
kartoffel selig sehr hin ich hab dir
auch so viele kartoffelgerichte wie wir
deutschen ja ja ist sehr populär ja habt
ihr auch kartoffelbrei kartoffelauflauf
wir haben ja fahne proben mit kartoffeln
kartoffelsalat haben wir sogar
kartoffelsalat ja kartoffelsalat ist auf
dänisch kartoffelsalat
ja das ist sehr populär pannen ja
vielleicht bratkartoffeln bratkartoffeln
bratkartoffeln und wie gut kann ein däne
deutsch verstehen ohne das zu lernen
das ist das ist schwierig
also wie wir hier sehen einige einige
wörter kann man schon verstehen aber wir
diese deutlich aussprechen
ja genau genau das ist eigentlich ja
aber ganze sätze nicht so wirklich
schnell
der kunde könne die uhr
hochschild es gibt die bahn bene bene
bekommt die bahn aber also wie gesagt
ist er kommt aus niederdeutsch also so
hat man das ausgesprochen
der zahn auf ständig gesagt ändern und
darum dass er dabei ganz anders
geschrieben
ja wir schreibt uns mit ein dänisches e
das ist das ist ein etf deutsch ja
eigentlich wir haben sehr viele lokale
viel mehr als auf lateinisch deshalb
brauchen wir und das ist schon das ist
trotzdem nicht genug also deshalb ist es
manchmal ein bisschen schwierig es
richtig auszusprechen
also haben jetzt noch kein richtig krass
das wort gehört wie ist es denn mit der
flasche es gibt lose deutsche haben wir
das mit dem andere wahl als das kino ist
aber kein oh du hörst es ist nicht ganz
so macht nochmal durch lose lose ist
anders
für mich klingt es ehrlich gesagt fast
nach hause
das ja viel ich weiß nicht ob leute das
verstehen würde dose nein es ist muss
dosis sein
nein nein stoße lose lose lose genau ja
sehr gut
rabattschlachten sagte luck die sind ja
alle endlich farbe farbe tasche tasci
aber tasche die ist auf deutsch kann
kann man sagen aber es kann auch die
diese taschen seien ja die hosentasche
ja aber auf den ich nicht
das sind das sind nicht tasci das ist ja
das ist nötig hast du dein handy enorm
wichtig
ja genau das klingt sie es richtig wenn
ja zu konstruieren auf deutsch spricht
man pcs sehr deutlich aber auf dänisch
sind die konsonanten nicht so wichtig
die vokalen ja aber die konsonanten
nicht also dcm geht schon
ich habe auch das gefühl dass er das ich
du kommst nämlich aus dieser stadt die
heißt unser ja genau
und die wird so auf deutsch wie diese
odense geschrieben und das war für mich
ich habe das lange üben müssen bissig
wohl so sagen konnte ja dass man nochmal
richtig und unser und so im prinzip
spricht man die konsonanten nicht oder
man spricht das wort einfach so als wäre
man betrunken ja dass das wird das wäre
eine beschreibung ja oder als hätte man
eine kartoffel und ja vielleicht also ja
die reise reise der strahl strom ist
rolle
hässlich ist lecker lecker
der inhalt in hall okay der stoff stoff
beginnen beginnen luft luft die pflicht
klickt der schmerz werde
das bringt sie leisten
ja aber auch heute klingt das härter der
schmerz schmerz der rücken
was genau das ist sehr gut den ich danke
schön dann die säule säule das rohr
malen mail ingwer ungefähr vorschlag
horsley dann haben wir fans also es gibt
einige wörter die klingen oder die seen
er nicht aus heißt noch etwas anderes
nämlich geld und das heißt was man womit
man bezahlt ja und dafür dänisch geld
geld genau das bedeutet dass auf dänisch
das sind schulden
oh das ist interessant sonst sage hey
schon nach der immer gesagt habe ich
aber viel geld haben bin ich nicht der
klingende in den 1
wenn man in deutschland ist und man
sieht geldautomat und denkt man nein
danke jetzt haben wir einige wörter
gelernt die im dänischen und deutschen
sehr ähnlich sind weil sie meistens
ursprünglich aus dem deutschen kommen
mich interessiert kann ich denn jetzt
mit meinem deutsch in dänemark richtig
durchstarten und was verstehen und jetzt
gucken wir mal ganz spontan auf eine
nachrichtenseite und ich guck mal ob ich
überhaupt verstehen es geht also
vielleicht liest du mal einen kurzen
text war ja und wenn jetzt hilft dann
ist das was politisches
und zwar denn konservative partie vom
man bekämpfe dort wo im juli die kommune
okay er sein kann also ein konservativer
partei vormann partei da drüben sind
welche am trinken und singen also der
konservative partei vormann das könnte
informant sein ein vorstand jemand der
der chef von einer partei ist genau
und der will camper vorfall in die vier
sind vier jahre genau also der
konservativen partei vorstand möchte
etwas für vier jahre machen genau und
kann abas kempin vielleicht im wald
kempen kempen für influenza in florenz
la und das deutsch einfluss einfluss ja
in kriens 1 also er möchte einfach
gewinnen indem er kämpft kämpft ja aber
kennt man im zelt kämpfen so arbeiten
ist also nicht so schwer aber ich hätte
jetzt gewährt er geht kämpfen
also wenn man wenn man deutschland kann
man auch sehr schnell den schülern würde
ich sagen das habe ich jetzt ein
bisschen motiviert ja ich dachte mensch
ist total schwerer wenn ich es höre
verstehe ich wirklich wenig aber ich
könnte ja zumindest lesen lernen
ja ich glaub ich glaube man muss einfach
einfach lernen dass es anders klingt
wenn man das weiß man dann geht es ein
fränkischer dann würde ich sagen vielen
dank henrik was du bei uns war es fängt
gerade an zu regnen
aber wir sind jetzt auch gerade fertig
geworden ich habe gelernt dass es sehr
viele worte gibt im dänischen die sehr
ähnlich sind zum deutschen und das heißt
wenn ich deutsch kann oder deutsch lerne
so wie ihr dann habe ich schon einen
schritt richtung gerne mal gemacht genau
und dann bin ich quasi schon ein freund
in dänemark und kann ganz einfach auch
die dänische sprache lernen und falls
ihr mal lust habt identisch sprache
kennenzulernen
zumindest mal zu sehen wie sich die
anhört und vielleicht wollte er ja auch
mal nach denen
gefahren wenn ihr schon in deutschland
seit dann schaut doch mal bei easy
dennis vorbei hier unten findet ihr die
playlist mit allen videos aus dänemark
und hier werden wir euch gleich noch ein
paar links einblenden zu einigen videos
aus der normalen danke schön dass du bei
uns was danke hat es hat mir freut mich
auch sehr erfreut und uns spaß gemacht
und das heißt es
[Musik]
[Applaus]